what is the do you think you have some
infatuation with death why are you able
to handle this sort of thing I couldn't
handle some of the images that we pulled
up right I mean really you know like
what what makes you think you're able to
digest that visually and um emotionally
and everything and how does it digest
for you yeah you know I started
Healthcare really young in life High
School all my friends were taking shop
and I decided to take a nursing aid
class I figured I'd be able to bathe the
girls well that didn't work out so well
that body shop homie I should have
talking about I should have took shop
but that would work but always had a
fascination with health care and then I
went into other things and at one point
uh cardiopulmonary respiratory therapy
so we manage life support systems so
okay so then you're getting close to
death so yeah an edge right there RT
does deals with trauma you know where
the the airway in that regard so we're
involved in in every uh traumatic death
RT when you say that respiratory
therapist okay are always in the ER
working for major codes and core
accidents and things like that so you
were around a lot of that so yeah I mean
we've managed the life support system
sometimes we have to pull the plug or
turn the machine off and that's what you
see you'd have to actually pull the plug
yeah well you turn them you just turn
the power off but yeah
um you'd think you'd at least pull the
plug like at least it's essentially you
do I mean you have to take the machine
out but you know terminating life
support on somebody
um
by the time you're at that stage they've
done uh brain tests to see if there's
any brain activity and these people
don't want to live on a machine you know
it's not like they're alive and talking
to you right at that stage but again we
see all you know we
we see a lot of trauma and I've always
had this I've always wanted to see I
wonder what paramedics and police see
um you know I wonder what what people
look like when they don't make it to the
ER
um I can remember having a uh my brother
was in the Iraq War the first one a long
time ago and he brought back some
pictures and he had some pictures of
extremities and things and I was just
fascinated to see that I don't know why
I was born that way I just I but I was
really fascinated to see some of that
and then I like card huh yeah and so
then later in healthcare and seeing
trauma
um we don't you know for someone that's
not in health care yeah it's it's hard
to see and imagine but
I don't you know I don't necessarily see
my eyes are I'm looking at science and
Anatomy you know that's just a femur or
that's just a brain this is parts of the
anatomy that that you know we've that
we've you know studied and seen before
yeah so it's not like I'm I'm seeing you
you know I'm not seeing Theo I'm seeing
right you know I just in general brain
and knees and whatever yeah I mean
people say how can you be a coroner
because you see bad stuff well an
orthopedic surgeon will take your arm
off and they're dealing with blood and
you know all kinds of things and they
remove your arm and then put it back on
you know so it's the same thing uh kinda
um it's just what we see
do you think there was a reason you got
into that line of work then do you think
there was like something that like you
had this like
you know this dark side that led you
into it it seems like you came a little
bit more through like the medical
profession so I I but I've always had a
uh I've always leaned towards Healthcare
I've always worked in the trauma area of
healthcare
um so you there's something fascinating
about it a little bit yeah I've always
just had it I was just born to do this
kind of stuff you know I don't I don't
do the coroner's office for money it's
not a you know I saved my best thing my
best friend's life and I look back on
that and you know it was a blessing to
have that yeah that ability Amen to be
able to just be there and be a part yeah
if you hadn't been there who knows yeah
so that's a real gift you know but yeah
I don't know what what shifted me into
it
um it's kind of like I was always uh set
up to do this kind of stuff yeah you
know and you can handle it absolutely
and to you uh your retired police
officer he was like man those guys can
eat yeah we can eat you know that
doesn't bother me I can eat a meatball
sub or boudin cracklins in an autopsy
break room damn you know when you're
hungry you hungry
boy I don't know I wouldn't have a
French dip though that seems a bit much
yeah if it's pretty good I like french
dip I would do that at home I think yeah
now we don't eat standing over a body
you gotta stand off to the side yeah
yeah yeah just there's a little break
room yeah yeah yeah
yeah plus down in Southeast Louisiana
bruh or if you're down in Southwest a
lot of the bodies down there could be
caused by Dustin Poirier too dude yeah
that's right if you're down to Southwest
Louisiana right if you got a good ass
whooping I'm not saying he's a serial
killer but uh definitely know right
right I bet if you CH you know yeah you
know fighting I had we had a young guy
died he was punched once and it was a
hard enough hit and he collapsed and hit
the cement and that's really unfortunate
but again it doesn't take much
you know
life's pretty fragile does it seem like
that it really is it really is every day
is a gift man some of the things we get
frustrated with with our family and and
friends
um or not worth the frustration because
they may not be here tomorrow or you
won't be here tomorrow you know and I
learned that yeah have you learned that
has that had a big effect on you that's
really fascinating yeah you're like this
is not a big deal yeah it's really not
you know you could be pumping gas and a
tire flies off a car and takes you out
you know
um I've had you know
single trees fall on cores you know just
the most bizarre
things but when God's ready for you he's
going to take you God the hardest part
and we were talking about suicides
earlier you know the blood and guts
don't bother me
um
but when for me anyway when I read a
suicide note that's what sticks with me
I can remember everyone I wrote I've
read for some reason it's personal at
that point not hey I'll be in the barn
come find me in the barn you know maybe
a child emails their suicide report uh
note to their family and can you imagine
and and or just a long letter it makes
it more personal and that sticks with me
longer than anything else and what is
what are those entail a lot of times if
you're looking through them notes what
are they putting in there
well you know don't blame yourself kind
of thing
um I'll always be an angel on your on
your shoulder and just your real
personal things you know I didn't do
this because of you or you know it's
it's
for some reason that sticks in my brain
more than than the actual scene
um
yeah it's just hard to deal with
sometimes you know that that changes the
the mood if you will
has there been a debt that was really
just blew your mind and how tough it was
to deal with that's something that maybe
it attached to something you had
personally in your life or an experience
to help you learn about yourself yeah
that's the that you know those are when
you'd ask me about personal ones I guess
when I see
um you know I have children and when
maybe like not that long ago I had a a
22 year old lose his dad and to watch
that 22 year old walk up to his father
in an ER you know I could imagine my
children coming to see me and and it you
know those hurt same as with babies and
you know all those things are hard to
see they really take a toll on us and
you know there is no out for us we have
to deal with it best we can
um they're not always easy you know my
Escape is music I listen to music on the
way there and I'll listen to music on
the way back and it's on the way home
and it's two different types of music
depending on what I've seen but we all
need that escape
uh yeah like what would you put on like
some Creedence Clearwater or what were
you like what kind of tunes are you
talking about or just something like a
like a Mozart or what are we yeah no I
mean my music my music tastes are all
over the map but you know um heading out
to scenes I'm I'm jamming to some Alice
in Chains or some Metallica And I'm just
getting in there
yeah yeah
I'd like to uh yeah I'm rocking but you
know when I'm leaving I'll go mellow
I'll go I'll go from you know maybe some
Counting Crows to some sometimes uh even
black gospel music I mean my brain just
goes to you know depends on the case and
the uh and what I see but yeah music's
gonna Escape for me you know it gets me
out of that
you know I don't do it I don't do this
full-time we all have other jobs we're
very uh or we're paid off of the budgets
and we don't have much I mean I I
literally when I go out and draw blood
on the weekends or or I visual fluid
when I get home I throw it in my fridge
at home and the butter and the butter
dish you know my kids know hey Dad I
found my little boy hey my dad has dead
people's blood in there yeah you know we
we we work around our jobs oh damn
that's Satan's condiment right there boy
damn that's a blast so I mean we we
we're really nerves bro we're really on
our own yeah my kids are desensitized
you know they back in the the early
Windows 98 when you could set your
screensaver to to just roll through your
pictures on your computers every once in
a while one would get away from me and
it would just be this really this gory
picture and I'd have to take it down but
uh
you know I've
you know yeah my kids are just
desensitized to say the least but they
hear me telling stories about what I'm
working with yeah and so they know how
dangerous drugs are they know yeah I
mean it's easy to even joke about you
know from being removed from it you know
it's like it's easy sometimes to try and
make levity of some of the situation you
know
um
what are there things you that you guys
have done like in the moment or things
ever that happened you try to keep some
levity in the situation because yeah the
only opposite to such a dark moment is
some levity you know yeah
we'll tease the officers
joke around with the officers on scene
not so much the person playing there but
um you try to pick up their spirits
you know um
in all sorts of ways you know sometimes
you can ask them to to hold something
and they think they're actually doing
something that needs to be done and
they're just holding a needle and you
know an hour later they're still
standing there holding that needle and
it's like you can let that go now you
know
um but yeah we you know you you have to
have a a bit of humor otherwise it'll
eat you up yeah